let's check in on the campaign of
Georgia Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker if you said to me David
sir what is the race that is depressing
you the most this year
Oz fetterman would be up there
Carrie Lake Katie Hobbs would be up
there there's some others that would be
up there but near or at the top of the
list has to be the Herschel Walker story
Herschel Walker can barely speak and
can't explain his political positions in
any kind of detail on any issue but most
importantly he is now embroiled in
multiple scandals in which he is just
straight up lying he has been caught
urging and paying for multiple women to
get abortions despite claiming to be
completely against abortion abortion is
murder according to him no exceptions no
exceptions no exceptions he's urged
multiple women and paid for multiple
women to get abortions he just denies it
he's obviously lying he has claimed
multiple times to be part of law
enforcement and they're just lies he
pulled out an honorary badge at a debate
was laughed at and then keeps pulling
the back badge out he's a liar liar liar
and the new unbelievable situation is
that the second abortion accuser
has now given an interview on television
she shows her face she's being referred
to as Jane Doe it's probably only a
matter of time until the woman is
identified but she's going by Jane Doe
but it's shown her face
and she says that Herschel Walker
essentially gave her an ultimatum about
the abortion you and the hypothetical
child would not be safe
if you chose not to have this abortion
think of that
listen to this from uh ABC News he did
not want me to have the child
and he said that
he said that because of his
wife's family and powerful people
around him that I would not be safe and
that the child would not be safe
that's very menacing
it is a very messy
and it's very messy now
[Music]
and I felt
threatened and I
I
thought I had no choice think about them
think about that if that is true this
guy is an absolute monster
now there is of course the hypocrisy
element to this
which we're going to deal with in a
moment but there is also the growing
understanding
this is not a nice guy he's threatening
the woman he impregnated and the
hypothetical child with not being safe
unless the woman gets an abortion his
own son
Christian Walker has said that he and
his mom had to move six times due to the
threats from Herschel Walker there is
nothing here that actually is meeting
the self-described standard he puts on
himself which is a great Christian man a
great father all these different there's
there's none of it whatsoever and even
if you don't care about the specifics
maybe you're a Georgia voter and you
don't care about the abortion issue
you care about his view on taxes you
could I couldn't tell you what it is but
you can understand it congratulations
but don't you care about the fact that
this guy is a menace and a liar does
that not matter at this point in time
and the answer is it very well may not
and that's what we're going to look at
next before you go if you enjoyed this
video and want to see more please make
sure to subscribe to my YouTube channel
you can click the Subscribe button below
or above or wherever it is on your
screen and if you want to support my
work even more strongly the best way is
to get a membership at joinpakman.com
And subscribe to the podcast for the
David packman show there you can check
out interviews longer clips and much
more it's on all the big podcasting
platforms just search for the David
packman show and all the links are also
Down Below in the video description